and we yesterday enjoyed readings from
Andrew hudkins andar MCG and a wonderful
performance by over the Ry uh and
tonight this afternoon and tonight looks
to continue that um be remiss of me not
to uh give a a word of thanks to Dan
sundall who founded this program 25
years ago uh and has been a was a
wonderful initiat
and who has handed it over to John
Somerville who's been a great Steward in
fact Dan shouted out from the audience
yesterday that when John said he's been
running the program Dan said perfected
the program and so those are high high
words of of
Praise today we're going to have a a
discussion about uh faith and the Arts
um before us we have all six uh
participants in this two-day cele
celebration I'd like to introduce you to
them uh one by one uh to to my left um
beginning on the on the far left is is
Suzanne W she received her ba and Ma
degrees from Oxford University her first
novel unveiling was published by
paraclet press and she's a co-author
with her husband Greg of several books
books that build character climb high
climb
far the family New Media guide bless
this house prayers for families and
children and Circle of Grace praying
with and for your
children she teaches English at Seattle
Pacific University and is the executive
editor at image and if that wasn't
enough she also blogs at
pathos to her right is Greg wo he's the
founder publisher and editor and chief
of image journal and the director of the
center for religious humanism and in
addition to that he's the director of
the MFA and creative writing program at
Seattle Pacific University he served as
a judge and nonfiction for the 2005
National book awards among his books are
Malcolm mugger a
biography a collection of his editorial
statements from image entitled intruding
upon the timus meditations on Art faith
and mystery and a collection of essays
entitled Beauty will save the world he
co-edited
God With Us rediscovering the meaning of
Christmas which I hear has gone out of
print and now is back in print and uh
the companion volume God for us for Lent
and Easter went out of print at the
beginning of Lent last year that's the
one that's now back in print okay thank
you so um so those those two uh he's
also the editor of the new religious
humanists a reader he's published essays
reviews and articles and new numerous
journals such as common whe first things
National Review crisis Modern Age and
New Oxford review he received his ba
Suma Kum LA from Hillsdale College and
his ma in English literature from Oxford
he's currently working on a book
entitled Christian humanism the faith
for All
Seasons Andrew hudgin is the author of
several collections of poetry including
a clown at midnight American Rend ing
new and selected poems ecstatic in the
poison Babylon in a jar Saints and
strangers after the Lost War a narrative
and the never ending he is a very
perceptive literary critic I find him to
be the best reader of jury Graham since
Helen vler and for every poetry Journal
that you can imagine he's been published
within its Pages he's written a memoir
entitled The Joker and he's also
published short stories he is a re
recipient of the of the writer bner
Award of the American Academy and
Institute of Arts and letters and was a
finalist for the peer prize with Saints
and strangers and a finalist for the
national book award for after the Lost
War he was a recipient of the poets
prize for after the Lost
war and I skipped Aaron McGrath you did
my
apologies Aon mcra received her MFA at
Indiana University and his lived in the
midwest ever since she teaches at the
Ohio State University and divides her
time between Ohio and Tennessee her
newest novel better food for a better
world was published last spring by slant
books a new imprint that Greg wol edits
he is Al she is also the author of the
novels the seamstress of Hollywood
Boulevard and the baby tree as well as a
short story collections The Good
Life lives of the Saints and bodies at
sea
we all had the privilege of listening to
Over the Rind last night native Ohioans
lynford deweer and Karen burquest
launched the group as a quartet in the
spring of 1989 naming The Ensemble after
the historic Bohemian Cincinnati
neighborhood over the Ry where they
lived and first wrote and recorded
together their early demos and
performance performances quickly struck
a chord with listeners and they already
had a solid local following by the time
they launched their recording career
with a pair of well-received
independently released albums till we
have faces and patience over the next
two decades Over the Rind continued to
build a musically and emotionally potent
catalog encompassing the studio albums
Eve good dog bad dog films for radio
Ohio drunkard's prayer the trumpet child
the long surrender and meet me at the
edge of the
world they have also recorded holiday
themed records the darkest night of the
year and snow
angels the live changes come and a
series of limited edition CDs that
feature live rare and unreleased
recordings a new album blood oranges in
the snow will be released in two weeks
on November 4th please join me in
welcoming all the panelists
[Applause]
we have three married couples before us
this afternoon and so the first question
I'd like to pose to you all is this how
important are stable relationships to
creativity writing and
Performing
uhoh well first of all stable I
mean
we're all looking at each other well
I'll say curiously that I did notice
that a lot of my favorite song writers
uh in recent years
were in uh long-term monogamous
relationships I would begin with Tom
weights one of my all-time favorites um
his wife is
his primary collaborator uh editor and
uh stage
designer
um Gillian Welsh and David Rawlings
aren't uh officially married I don't
think but they've been together probably
at least 15 years or more um writing and
touring together depends on the law on
whatever state there that's right that's
right that's right that's right that's
right that's
right um who else buddy and Julie Miller
Joe Henry Joe Henry they've been hitched
for some time right pardon me you've
been hitched a long time Joe and M yeah
Joe and and M our producer yeah
beautiful
couple
J yeah and we had the privilege of going
out with a a bass player and a drummer
probably the most sought-after drummer
in the US right now Jay Bose and uh
they've been been in a relationship for
well over a
decade and
um some of the people that you would
think you know have gone down a
different
path um one might think of Leonard Cohen
and I remember something that he said um
along the lines of you know I've been
privileged to be called a singer I could
barely carry a
tune um
I've been called I've been lucky enough
to be called a poet you know maybe I did
write a few things
and and I I was also called a ladies man
which which was a
joke and all I can do is think of all
the nights I cried bitterly
alone so maybe there's something to be
said for having a trusted editor
somewhat nearby and um a little bit of
stability who knows I think it's also
because we share a common passion I mean
obviously for each other but but but for
something outside of us something
something you know language
music uh something that draws us both in
the same direction I like that well
people have asked us many times all
those collaborations on those books you
wrote together that must have been
oh and and and really I I mean with the
exception of a few moments here and
there um I've been I've always told
people when it comes to the writing
we've done together it's it's the good
of the object made that we care about
and it's the rest of our married life
that screw screwed up you know yeah yeah
well no I mean you know it's it's not
the writing and it's not even the kids
too because that's the good of the you
know that they made too uh it's like how
many shoes I bought last week whatever
right
yeah or you know the fact that I when he
gets grumpy about that and I remember
that only the previous week he dropped
like $5,000 on some piece of
electronics 2000 you
know
2000 see some number
yeah um I mean some some things are
harder to take than others some things
sink in
slowly but right are you still talking
editorial critique creative differences
yeah yeah well well I mean you you you
probably you know Greg and I are very
different I mean we collaborate but
we're totally different with the way we
approach writing for
example um you know what was it you were
you were explaining the other day to one
of the kids on the phone you said
something like Greg is like he has to
you have to kind of get everything kind
of all the teas crossed and all the eyes
dotted I outline he outlin basically
obsessively okay hey it's really Tommy
at Hillsdale outline your papers and I
just like jump
in I I literally jump in with with with
a sentence like I a first sentence I
mean and then see how that grows
organically I don't know how how about
you
guys um we uh we are each other's first
readers um and and um over the years a
informal rule has come up in the house
that nothing leaves the house without
the other one signing off on it because
Andrew has saved me from too much
embarrassment and vers of
us but the way I hear that question that
that dton post had
um I just think
that um stability for an artist is a
smart thing in general and flar says
somewhere that uh it's good to live like
a bgea so that you can write like and
the the translation is very sometimes it
says a Madman but my the translation I
like better says you can write like an
archangel and you know in his case that
meant living in his mom's house uh and
letting her cooking food while he wrote
These tormented letters to his mistress
in Paris but
um but but it worked I um I do think
that it's very useful to get as much
noise out of my head as possible and and
to live in a a a quiet and contained way
and for sure a stable relationship is
the major part of that absolutely and I
I think that it does then open up other
energies to create right well it's
important to us because it's important
to us um we
um we come to that and we want that
stability and um all of us obviously and
therefore we're in these um marriages
that are long-term marriages but I
certainly know as Lyford suggested
people who thrive on chaos who um who go
out and screw around or whatever they do
to get turmoil in their lives and then
they Retreat into their work as some way
of I mean it's not a way that I want to
live it's it's that form of chaos and
Madness but I've certainly seen people
do that and I imagine you have too the
um for me it's a different thing when I
I mean I I sit down with the writing and
I try to write every day job stops me
from doing that a lot of the time but
I've always tried to do that when I was
married to my first wife I did it when I
was not married to my first wife I did
it when I was married Aon I continue to
do it the difference is um that was
poetry mostly some pros but in this
marriage um in this marriage in the
marriage um I've been able
to let Aaron help me write Pros in way
that I was nervous about unwilling to
really throw myself over into a new
discipline um and she's she certainly
helped me with that could I have done it
otherwise you maybe maybe not I don't
know it's not a life I have to live and
um but yeah for me personally for us
personally and imagine since we're all
here um yeah stability is is a lovely
wonderful
and helpful
thing I would just add to that that for
me um our relationship has been very
encouraging both ways and we've also had
to learn how to be soft editors with one
another because we are in such close
contact with what we do it's a it's
constant it's not like I have this and
he has this we have this thing together
so um it's a little more intense um and
we've had to I think learn and probably
will continue to uh learn how to um be
gentle with that but still objective um
and for me
personally I I didn't really realize how
much routine I needed and so I got three
dogs and um there's a chaos in in it a
little little bit at this point in my
life however um they have provided um
stability through routine for me which
is something I didn't know I needed
until I had it and um I had no structure
to my day and I think artists struggle
with that or writers or whatever and um
um so yes I I say thumbs up to the
stability and my energy goes
into U positive things rather than
chaos
I would just like to point out that all
the women on the panel on this
particular panel I love to hear all of
them laugh very good
laughers I'm not sure if that's
important or not totally
important I think it
is Suzanne had me worried at the
beginning there when I chose stable
little long term but now I'm glad I did
well this is the question that I I have
to ask uh so um it's
1989 image and Over the Rind have just
formed image's first issue is published
and the album till we have faces comes
out in
1991 Andrew's followup to the peer prize
nominated Saints and Sinners after the
Lost War has been published in
1988 Aaron has published a a short story
in the fifth issue of image in
1990 what are the main differences
between the audiences you had in the
early 90s and the audiences you have now
what are the main cultural differences
between 1989 and
2014 way better clothes
now way better
clothes and
hair and hair
that's true for a very brief time we
were in 80s
band big hair and mullets padded
shoulders yeah yeah well Greg is an
added to you probably that's that's a
pitch right down in the middle for you
come on
Wolf well I know I mean it's I've really
got a Spiel on it and uh but it
certainly doesn't cover all of our
different various experiences so I hope
everyone will chime in well when we
started image of course we we were you
know pretty skeptical about what the
reception would be um I mean one of the
reasons we started image was that um a
very strange thing seemed to be
true millions of religious folk and
almost all the cultural Gatekeepers of
the secular World seem to agree on
something which theoretically they
shouldn't but they seem to agree that
Contemporary Art in literature that
seriously engage the ancient Western
Faith Traditions was not possible
anymore and that that odd agreement the
very fact that two completely disperate
communities would would agree on the
same thing kind of pissed us off in a
way I mean I think anger is an
underrated source of human
motivation um or let's say righteous
wrath I don't care you know dudon you
know high dudgeon I'd go for medium
dudgeon you
know
um and we wanted we believed that that
was that that couldn't be true you know
that um as I was saying to somebody last
night it's say or yesterday as if as if
people at least the religious folks
thought that the Holy Spirit was locked
up in a cage in some dungeon somewhere
that this couldn't happen that Western
hi had Di died at some point and so what
we were kind of nervous about was you
know who would be the most hostile to
what we were trying to
do um was the religious audience going
to vilify us for you know trying to uh
share this material uh that didn't
explicitly pontificate that didn't have
mission statements or characters who
stood up and were the V vehicles of
Truth uh in a in a narrative um for
example um were the secular critics
going to dismiss us I mean the the
secular argument was classic it was kind
of Third Rate freudianism because as we
remember you know Freud and this is
really his weakest side I don't mean to
diss him completely but he wasn't really
great on religion and he said it was
wish fulfillment and escapism and so the
old argument was that if if real art is
about money sex and power kind of the
Ultimate Reality of human life and
religion was escapism then how could
they ever mix there was no way they
could ever mix because religion just
goes and it makes you uh you know uh it
just takes you away from the struggle
that needs to take place within your
characters within your imagery and so on
well what we had begun to notice at
least by
1989 was that uh whereas say in the 70s
60s or 70s new yor the New York Times
book review would have a book review
that would say I remember one in
particular of a novel by Larry wwoody
not necessarily one of his best but it
was not a bad novel called Papa John and
it is a story that actually has a
conversion a Christian conversion story
in it and it's it's very gritty it's
it's about an alcoholic actor who's very
down and out and who who sort of gets
more and more degraded and he has this
bottoming out experience anyway when
Joyce Carol oats you know reviewed that
book it was with utmost scorn you know
it started this book started so well and
then woo religion came in and blah blah
blah what I what we were beginning to
notice even from
1989 was that the book reviews and those
kind of venues were beginning to say
things like maybe of a review of a
Reynolds price novel or something like
that how interesting that the faith
however tinged by doubt or tentative of
this
protagonist called urges that person to
a deeper engagement with the world
forces them in a sense to have to
Grapple with the world that they might
otherwise wish to escape whoa There Was
You Know A Change happening and um and I
think that change uh really began you
know continued from that time onward so
that at least now there's a greater
porousness in in the mainstream cultural
organs I mean look at the way Marilyn
Robinson's Lila is being reviewed right
now and not just in National Review or
National Catholic Reporter or
Christianity today but the New Yorker
and the Atlantic and and so on um people
have maybe it's sometimes grudging
respect but they if the work is there
and this was always our trust if the
work was there which is why we had to
pick excellent work then we hoped and
prayed that it would gain that hearing
and we feel that that's been the
experience for image and the the change
in the religious community has been been
huge I
mean there are now Church churches for
example non-denominational churches that
have like permanent Gallery space in
their Church Sanctuary to have art shows
up all the time it's like an amazing
change has gone on PE people got sick of
pmics and apologetics and realized that
we needed the imagination to address the
mystery of of the spiritual
life well I've certainly noticed Ohio
State um well I was teaching at
Cincinnati I was there for 16 years that
overlapped a little bit with the time
we're talking about actually we left
about in 2001 um the students there very
few were writing in any kind of
religious tradition would you agree with
that Y and now at Ohio State more of our
students are interested in it um for a
while it was it was a little bit because
I was there Aaron was there and our
colleague David satino was there and um
we would get
um students that would they were kind of
keeping quiet about it but then they
would come and talk to us more more
would kind of come in and let their hair
down with you wouldn't they well there
when we were still in Cincinnati there
Greg's heard this story
before this would have been mid90s uh a
student came into my office closed the
door behind her looked at me with this
hunted look on her face and said I want
to write about
religion and that I I don't think that
she would feel so uh so hunted now I
think that she'd be a lot more
comfortable with that she would find a
lot more space and and she'd find
respect from her peers that she
certainly didn't find
them and you know when those students
come we put copies of image in their
hands the um um it's really
it's interesting that we don't have as
much as we used to and Greg would
understand too that when we get
applications from students from Bible
colleges they are smart and they are
incredibly untrained as artists and it
just breaks your heart because you do
think that if these were people that
went and got training as artists they
could be the um a voice that would work
within the tradition as artists but
because they have no
instruction they are we we can't take
them we've got too many good people that
are already working at a at a high level
and what I do with my own students and
actually sometimes when I go off to um
smaller colleges I'll say look if you
want me to meet with your religious
colleges I'll meet with your students
and I can try to walk them through some
of the basics but in truth it's going to
be too little most of the time so what
I'm trying to do is give them some
pointers and then point them to um The
Glenn conferences or to places where
they can do an MA with in literature and
take um creative writing classes and
then they can be up to Snuff to do an
MFA at a program that they aim to um and
again your MFA program are
working you know they they're doing that
work in the fields too um but I find the
students more open to it the ones that
are open to it are open to it the ones
that are uninterested in it are deeply
and profoundly uninterested but they are
not as
antagonistic as they used to
Beal an exception just floated through
but um Greg had mentioned that we were
afraid of the sort of the Hostile we
were wondering from what direction the
hostility would come when we first
published the pilot issue of image in
'89 and uh we soon learned because we
were at a Catholic college and I was
immediately
fired because yeah and then Greg
resigned and it was because of image and
they had taken exception to the art that
we had put in there and I was Dean of
women I wasn't fired as a teacher of lit
I was fired as dean of women because I
was
deemed not therefore sort of morally
appropriate to oversee the lives of
young
women which was true of course which is
true by
do well but we had we had a we had a
long essay on John Updike the use of sex
in John updike's fiction we had a front
cover that had a beautiful I thought
still do beautiful modern triptic it was
very subtly a triptic it showed this big
panel with was like what they call Trump
ly um effects that were where they had
masking taped three images and the image
what central image was was of a kind of
screaming man which is clearly a man in
agony and one was of a of a ladder like
makes you think of the deposition of
Christ coming down from the cross and
then on the right was this beautiful uh
9 months pregnant nude woman seen from
the side with the tiniest tiniest bit of
pubic hair visible okay I mean this was
not puran it was like reverent yeah I
mean this was an adoration this was the
mother of God in a sense metaphorically
but at a Catholic College you mess
around with the Virgin Mary and you show
her nude goodbye it's over so yeah we
did pay a price there um for sure but uh
luckily it got better from that point
onward though not immediately not
immediately I mean that we had
uh I don't know that I can add a whole
lot but I mean
musically in 1989 Karen and I grew up in
uh the church around a lot of gospel
music my father was a minister so there
was this question should we try to be on
a Christian label or should we you know
just forge our own path or try to be on
a major label or or what and we made the
decision that we wanted to take our
music to the general Marketplace
wherever people at large were finding
music in a in a record store or going
into a particular venue in their town to
hear interesting songwriters we wanted
to just show up on the scene with our
work in kind of a neutral setting we
didn't want to go around to church youth
groups and and play music you know so
that was a decision but um there was um
all sorts
of subtle gospel music influences in our
music so we did get occasional um
invitations from Christian festivals or
Christian colleges to come perform and
there were some interesting moments
um
uh first of all um Cornerstone Festival
in Illinois uh was sort of a Music and
Arts Festival that's no longer in
existence Green Belt Festival in England
Flo festival and Holland they all
invited us to come and play um and and
for the most part
um embraced us but we were this odd duck
that went out and we would play in clubs
all year long and then we'd play one or
two Christian festivals you know and
um and that was very odd in the early
90s and now I think it's it's not even
wouldn't even cross a young kid that had
grown up in the church it wouldn't even
be an issue across their mind at all
that they you know of course they should
take their music just and play it in the
club whatever that was downtown and and
just get it out there so um and there
were a few interesting um you know
Christian colleges that would invite us
to come play and then somebody would
open a record and see a picture of a
sculpture at the Muse dors of a of a
nude just legs and just legs this Panic
would begin to you know to go across
campus that uh you know oh my goodness
what are we getting ourselves into and
there were some interesting stories
where you know we were asked not to come
yeah shows were canceled and things like
that that so we tried to be very open on
the front end about now are you sure you
know what you're signing up for
um are you okay with the art in Muse D
yeah but thankfully I I really don't
think for the most part that people
would be wasting their time on those
sort of peripheral conversations at this
point I think the mostly the
conversation would be is this good
interesting music that we should bring
to our campus and
I I think there's been some steps
forward oh yeah our our audience is
definitely older now as well that's one
big difference and um it we also have
younger Generations coming in but it's
far more diverse I think now than it
used to be and and so that's a really
interesting thing to sort of nurture I
think we have learned
um the importance of gratitude over over
the 25 year span I think when you're
young and you're kind of an upstart you
get in there and you just kind of you go
full steam at least in in our genre um
but the the one thing that we've learned
uh over those 25 years is gratitude and
not to coddle or cater to an audience
but you learn how to nurture the
audience and
um and I think that that maybe has
affected
um our relationship with them over the
years as
well yeah we love our diverse audience
and as far as it growing somewhat older
thank God because they have more
money well not when they're paying the
sitter they
don't
this question is a followup to the last
one we're all well aware of how the
publishing industry has changed because
of the internet with the exception of
Andrew who's had seven out of his nine
books published with the same press the
majority of you have gone with several
different
Publishers in fact at this point Over
the Rind began with IRS records uh but
now has its own record label great spec
dog and Greg is the editor for slant
book books how is the infrastructure for
developing new tallent changed and
what's available for emerging artists
today again Greg I right down
here your Aly well yeah I mean nobody
knows how all this is going to shake out
that's the problem I mean there there
there are beautiful things about what
technology is making possible well for
one thing it's decentralizing the
production process which means that the
big conglomerates are no longer the the
the the narrow bottleneck through which
everything has to pass and ultimately
that's that's a healthy thing I mean yes
they were Gatekeepers and Arbiters of
taste and I'm a strong believer that
that is an important we need curators of
culture we need people we can whose
judgment we can trust but there were it
was like when we only had three channels
I mean now we got a million and we're
complaining about that but but the truth
is that you can even make a film these
days you know that's how radical it is
you can make a film these days with
something you can hold in your hand and
put it up on the big screen and that
means that that that there is there's
not so much a barrier to
entry the concomitant problem is that
anybody can put anything out there and
that problem of curation remains as well
as of sales and as well as of
cohesiveness of Market of the market and
I know that you know each of us has
struggled we want our work to appear
under some Authority greater than
[Music]
ourselves you know so I caution anyone
before self-publishing I know it's so
tempting just to push a button and have
Amazon deliver your book to you but you
know reputations and careers do require
some nurturing and some thought
and you know in in the era of instant
gratification hold back your first
impulse on that
score um but on the other hand nobody
knows how to make any
money and so um we're all trying to find
out how to you know get honest pay for
honest work and that that really hasn't
shaken out fully at this point but the
need for curators is still there and I
think that's where people are beginning
to look for the small Indie press the
Grey Wolves the SAR bands whatever
they're I think now looming larger than
they ever had in the past because they
know that the many of the books they're
publishing are not going to be the mega
sellers by TV celebrities and movie
stars and sports stars but they they're
the ones that are going to take care God
willing of of the better work and no
one's going to make a lot of money so
yeah consider a day job
people well and and the Grey Wolves and
the sah don't have unrealistic
expectations voed on them by corporate
Overlord uh the corporations that have
bought them
out uh well it used to be uh and now I'm
going way a good little ways back say 40
years ago it was expected that um a book
would
earn maybe would make back maybe two or
3% for the the company that published it
small little margins and that and
companies were based on that expectation
and contracts were issued on that
expectation that has changed and now
we've got publishing houses that are
owned by multinational conglomerates who
have an expectation that every book is
going to bring back a return of anywhere
between 10 to 25% that's ludicrous that
that's just so so so not possible
ludicrous for literary publishing
ludicrous for literary publishing and
it's frankly it's ludicrous for a lot of
commercial publishing too but it
explains why commercial writers are
writing so much more now um and and and
when you don't when you've got grey wolf
when you've got San when you've got
slant when you've got El gonin when
you've got these places that have a more
realistic expectation of what their
books are going to bring back and their
projections are based on that you've got
companies that are able to function at a
sane level and and it's just you can
tell the difference when you go to these
editorial offices if you go over to New
York people are losing their minds
they're frightened and and jobs are on
the line all the time you go to Sarah
band people are having coffee yeah
what's that um publishing house that
just recently went
nonprofit um mcweeny
mweene yeah and you know you would you
would have thought well they're super
HIIT they know how to make money you
know no not really you know they're
they're putting out some pretty finely
cra Ed stuff it's not it's not just you
know it's not it's not sugar it's not
you know sugar dad sugar babies that you
just Nom Nom and dispose of um takes
time to get get work your way into one
of their special issues and you got to
sit with it so they've made the
shift well in the Poetry World we've
already the people who've worked with
commercial house hous is shrunk um far
Strauss and jaru still does a poetry
line
um hotton harcour does um but um a lot
of the people that used to do these
don't anymore there's more money in it
it's all exactly what eron said the um
then we started moving to the university
presses now the university presses are
cutting back on it for the same
financial reasons
and when um students come to me I don't
really quite know what to tell them um
what will get them an academic job um
the the number of people pursuing the
slots the diminishing number of slots is
gotten larger um the number of jobs out
in the world has gotten smaller the um
we I think we try to be upfront about
that um and people are doing the because
they want to be artists the um the
independent houses are coming in smaller
presses are coming up something like
able Muse which I'm sure you've not
heard of small press with an emphasis on
formal poetry that's doing extremely
good work um and so I think that's one
of the places my students and my
colleagues um who've had experiences
with larger presses that now are no
longer doing portra that is that is a
place in places like that that they are
going how the internet works into this
and how internet publishing works I
don't know I mean all of academ is were
trying to figure that out because it's a
matter of curating how does it work
where you take it to a um an outside
Review Committee and that outside review
is rigorous and thorough
and your book comes out with Harvard up
but is there a Harvard up online no so
when Steven greenblat was head of um the
MLA and he came out and he said that
they should we should accept online
publishing fully as the equivalent of
publishing with Oxford University press
Harvard University press you know you
look at it and you go okay Harvard you
start they're not going to do that not
they're not going to do it so they are
you know he's trying to establish a
certain standard for everyone else that
he doesn't want to hold his people to so
I honestly don't know what to tell my
students though you know I have a woman
Ashley McHugh who has a ma an
undergraduate from Ohio State a ma from
um Boston University an MFA from the
University of Arkansas and an
award-winning book that won that new CR
ieron prize she is now happily working
as a manager in a in a company and
pleased to have a 40-hour week job and a
better paycheck than she was getting as
um as a teacher in a um at a branch of
the University of Arkansas and I think
we're going to have more of that we have
there's nowhere else to
go that's the happy
news the good news is people are
continuing to follow an artistic
passion probably some overlap in the
music world of course uh you know when
we first started out in the early 90s it
was all about trying to get the major
label record deal and we worked really
hard to do that and got on a quote
unquote major label and it was caused
for great
celebration and um two or three records
in we realized that uh there was no way
we were ever going to sustain a career
in music if we kept giving away our our
records and our songs to a major record
label Lock Stock and Barrel for very
little in return really at the end of
the day it's uh a little bit like um
going to a bank and um saying I would
like to buy a house and or or maybe even
build a house and the bank giving you
the money and then you pay all the money
back at very
um you know steep return at a very steep
rate of return or whatever and then the
bank owns your house forever once you
finally pay them back that was the major
label model you know so you end up
owning nothing um but they give you the
little bit of money up front to help
Grease the wheels or whatever ever so in
'96 we
said screw it let's just start putting
out our own records and owning our own
music we'll just see what happens and
and well there was a transition before
that though where we actually had uh
encountered a lawyer that was very smart
and had was married to another musical
uh performer in her family and
negotiated for us first he planted the
seed that you could you can negotiate
getting your records back after a decade
so that there was a transition he sort
of planted a seed for us and after a
certain point we started to get our
material back yeah we won 100%
independent for a while then we tried a
model with a label where our music
reverted back to us at some point so
somehow we managed to end up owning most
of our music um from the last few
decades which has allowed us to continue
to make music but it's been a very
uh you know um uncertain
path forward and and now with
downloading and everything it's still
you know a bit nebulous um I can say
that you know what hasn't changed in the
last 25 years is the work itself you
know the Dilemma of the blank page and
trying to create something
that you know feels somehow
connected to uh the writer and
um you know it feels like a well-made
thing that
whole that that part never goes away
never changes and and that's what
probably keeps us all coming back I
think somehow you know there's a little
bit of a leap of faith you you you
believe that if you continue to do your
best work that um hopefully people will
continue to find it and appreciate it
and somehow
um somehow you can keep keep moving
forward I think just raise your
standards with your work and lower your
expectations with with how it's received
because we don't get to sit on on the
committee that decides what happens
after it's out there so you have to
check why you're doing it what's your
motivation and if it's if it's to create
something important that matters and uh
translates to someone else and it's good
work then I think that's a really good
reason to move
forward but the rest you have to let go
of in the music world uh Greg at this
point you know I can remember that
feeling of like oh should we put our
music out ourselves you know isn't that
how's that going to work you know we're
not on Warner Brothers anymore or
whatever well it's all vanity publishing
now in in the music world in the music
world cuz uh the major labels
imploded right and crashed and
burned and uh so so in the music we just
put it out ourselves yeah I think it's a
different it's a different Criterion
that people apply to music I mean okay
definitely first of all many many of the
you know artists who've done that have
already had a track record but okay but
you know ultimately that's a place where
I mean music is a tad more of a popular
medium than
literature and so I think there are ways
that people look for the critics and you
know the websites and
uh past magazine and so on they there
are still curators out there it's not so
much the publisher doing it as it's the
the intermediate realm so I think that
it's I knew you were going to say that
that is that is in fact the truth it's
it's a little trickier with with writing
I definitely
definitely still
M have time for one more question
or
all right so um I guess it's just kind
of a a general question who are the uh
singer songwriters uh poets short story
writers novelists visual artists and
essayists that we should be reading
today the people that that you
admire looking at me again I can I can
save please help save
me well I I worship corat McCarthy so
you haven't read now buckle up because
blood meridian's a bit of a ride uh but
you know there's far worse on TV blood
you know blood and and Gore um oh yeah
uh major
major um and over to you whilst I think
of more because because my mind just
went
blank
um well Tim Winton yeah I mean we should
probably I I I feel like mentioning
people who might not be is well known
because you know these guys might want
like those kind of recommendations so
Tim Winton an Australian novelist uh
Cloud street um dirt music his most
recent book is called Eerie um wonderful
writer just incredibly gifted writer if
you have a taste for um dense poetry
that's sort of densely elusive to
history and another literature I think
Jeffrey Hill the British poet is uh he's
one of those writers like Elliot who is
hard yes but fulfills the requirement
that any difficult writer H has to have
applied to him or her which is does it
repay the effort and he'll I always feel
repaid I look up the Illusions and I
reread the poem and and I feel you know
a better broader human being for it so
anyway I don't want I know we're kind
tight on time so I Dutton sent these P
these question question out to us come
on suzan I am particularly glad he did
because this is the kind of question
that sends me straight into brain freeze
so I was able to to come in prepared
three writers about Place uh one whose
name we've been throwing around a lot
the last couple of days Morris Manning
he's a poet from Kentucky Morris spelled
like Maurice and uh he's a very very
interesting very strange very wide
writer you never quite know what you're
going to get with Morris uh a short
story writer named Claire ve Watkins he
writes about her home state of Nevada
she's got a book out called battleborn
which is Nevada state
motto and it's uh absolutely worth
looking at she's got a singular voice
and another uh short story writer and
novelist named Holly G Jones who is
creating her own fictional place called
Roma Kentucky based on uh Southwest
Kentucky where she grew up and she's
she's not quite turning it into yaka
county yet but uh she's creating
something something very real and and
very beautiful so those would be my
three I know you all know John Sullivan
who was here recently we're always
pleased when we see um John in the
Sunday Times magazine the um a name that
surprises me that I'm going to mention
is Tom mcain um I used to read the young
mcain and not see the point um but um
the mcain that's publishing in the New
Yorker or when those show up I know I'm
going to read that he's really doing a
terrific job Morris again and po a
couple of poets Bridget Kelly um you
published Bridget I haven't I've written
her a letter I didn't get a response she
never responds she's um she lives in her
own world but she's a terrific writer
and so is Linda Gregerson who teaches at
University of Michigan those are just
some names that you know right off the
top of my
head well ours probably won't be that
much of a surprise we've been um
mentored by Joe Henry who I think is an
unsung writer he is stupendous and
um cares about the craft and he well
he's had some great successes popularity
uh with a couple of songs he likes to
say that he writes songs and and in this
one example his sister-in-law Madonna
wrote the hit made it a hit um but
there's it's quality material um another
another um that would wouldn't be much
of a surprise is the Milk Carton Kids um
Kenneth Paton gaale and Joey Ryan we've
worked with them they are we actually
just collaborated with them and Joe
Henry on a separate project where the
five of us got together for three days
and wrote I don't know how many songs
but
um they are Young Voices uh great talent
very thoughtful very smart and they're
doing something uh pretty fresh
um and I have my go-tos that will always
be there because their voices have
their singing voices and their also
their their writing voices meant so much
to me and one of which is um lucenda
Williams um she knows what she's doing I
don't need to say anything else um about
her writing um that's probably enough
that's great I'll just add loud and
Wayne Right if you don't know his
writing it's rufus's
Dad check out his records uh he's he's a
heavy
hitter thank you so much for
participating in the discussion and uh
I'd like everyone to invite everybody to
hear uh Greg wol speak tonight at 8:00
and there will be a reception afterward
where there will be uh brownies and
books to sign and great conversation so
I look forward to seeing you then and
please extend a a note of thanks to
everyone on the
panel